recording okay hey guys bandit here
um it's been a while since i've done a
video kind of like this am i okay the
audio is good i think we'll we'll figure
out if the audio is good anyway it's
been a while since i've done a video uh
like this one just
just me and you guys just talking in
fact i think the last time that i did
something like this was for the 50 000
subscriber thank you
uh which was obviously
well over a hundred thousand subscribers
ago so yeah it's it's been a while um
anyway how have you guys been doing
i hope you've been doing great
um i'll have you know i've been doing
well
i guess
um
you know i'm sure you can tell some
things are are different with me uh not
just the background well i guess the
background is different in that
i'll tell you what's the story behind
that i guess i'm in a new apartment now
um if you hadn't
seen some of the recent videos where i
mentioned that i am in a new apartment
now it's really nice um it's
like a one bed one bath it's nice for me
and uh for gannon um my little puppy dog
um who is actually sleeping out there
right now um so i can't be too loud
because you know it's it's kind of later
right now and he's he's sleeping so
anyway i don't want to wake him up but
yeah i'm in a new apartment now um
things are going really well my hair is
getting longer you know
um but i i also wanted to say that
things are are going well um because
of you guys
like
you know i i don't mean to get
super sappy so quickly into the video
but that's kind of one of the things
that i wanted to touch on here because i
never want uh to go for too long like
to go for over a hundred thousand
subscribers without touching base with
you guys and letting you know just how
much i appreciate
each and every one of you like seriously
you have no idea
i
you guys might not know but um the
majority of my income uh for my life
comes from doing content like this on
youtube and that is something that i
thought i would never be able to do
if you were to have talked to me two
years ago three years ago i would have
been like oh yeah i know i have the
channel up but that's just kind of to to
have fun you know on and just kind of to
do things on i would have never ever
thought that this would be what i do and
you guys have given me that opportunity
and i will forever
forever be grateful for it so
really honestly thank you guys so much
from the bottom of my heart i i will i
will never be able to say thank you
enough
um
on that note um the the
primary
reason for this video i guess in
addition to just touching base with you
guys and saying hi to all the new faces
out there um and saying thank you in
addition to that um is giving you kind
of a
i guess an explanation
for what's
been going on with the channel
i if that makes sense um
i've been seeing in in some comments you
know uh
you guys are starting to notice that um
my content is kind of
a little bit all over the place you know
it's it's it's over here a little bit
it's over there i'm i'm
talking about different franchises doing
different styles of videos and i wanted
to kind of uh explain
the purposes behind that to you guys so
story time um and i'm sorry i'm trying
to do this just as real as i can i'm not
even planning on on editing this video
really at all so this is just me just
just word
vomiting and i apologize for the amount
that of of rambling potential that
exists in me as a human being
i apologize for that uh but anyway
oh i'm getting a call
this from me father sorry dad i will
call you back give me a second anyway um
story time
when i started this channel
um three or four years ago or whenever
it was and and i i wasn't
uploading
frequently or anything like that i i
literally just started a channel because
i had a
thought and that thought was
i i want to entertain people i want to
make content
that can be entertaining to people that
so so that i can meet these people
uh and
be friends with them uh
and that that's
why i made the channel in the first
place and you know because i had uh i
guess kind of a lack of people
immediately surrounding me in real life
that
really shared my interests um
you know like zelda for example i mean
obviously i'm a really big zelda fan i
don't know anybody in real life like
like
what i mean by in real life because
everybody's in real life but you know
what i mean by that is like i don't
physically know anybody that i've seen
and talked to
that is
half as big of a a gaming geek as all of
us are here at mass nintendo bandit and
so you know and that's
that was the notion behind trying to
make a gaming channel
now
notice
i didn't say
that i wanted to start the channel
to be a zelda theory channel
which is what i became
and i i think i actually did mention
this back in my 50 000 subscriber thank
you video um that i was going to try to
branch out well that's because initially
i wanted to do all sorts of stuff um
the real ones no no i'm just kidding but
you know some some of the people who for
whatever reason decided to follow this
weirdo way back when in the early days
you might remember that i had some let's
plays up on this channel and i
talked about games like the the the
arkham batman games um and and uh
bloodborne and things like that like i
talked about all sorts of stuff and i
know you're like oh man mass nintendo
bandit what's nintendo bandit doing
talking about all this other stuff well
i always saw that as just kind of i
don't know call it my gamer tag if you
will i'm a nintendo fanboy sure but i
play all sorts of stuff
but anyway that was always the purpose
behind the channel but the only thing
that really ever
took off was um when i started talking
about zelda which i am extremely
passionate about i think you can see
that that right there
that nintendo 64 right there in the
frame that is an actual nintendo switch
that is my actual nintendo 64 that i
played when i was
zero years old you know i mean like
not really but you know what i mean one
of the first memories of my life
is playing ocarina of time on that very
nintendo 64 with my grandfather may he
rest in peace phenomenal man he never
really uh was around for any of this
stuff i'm i would have loved to have
conversations with him about it but
anyway that's near the here nor there
where was i
see this is the problem with with being
a rambler like i am anyway
like i was saying i never intended to be
a zelda theory channel in the first
place
um and that's what i became and that's
where all of you guys are from and that
that is great that is phenomenal zelda
there are only two things that i'm
blindly passionate about in this life
and that is it's zelda and batman
which is why i had covered a batman game
on the channel um the all the i mean i
like so many other things but those are
the two franchises that i'm just like
die hard over
and uh
so obviously i'm very happy
to not just be able to have a channel
based on so far zelda theories but to be
one of the
bigger zelda channels out there i mean
that's just that's insane to me you know
the amount of the community
that my content influences like you can
find my stuff other places on the web or
on reddit
that's insane that's just mind-blowing
to me but anyway what i was trying to
say was i never meant to become that
only
you know what i mean i never meant to
pigeonhole myself
um
and so
i guess what i'm
wanting to ask you guys is
is it okay if i try to not pigeonhole
myself
is it okay if i try to
[Music]
do other things now i i don't don't get
me wrong i'm not trying to say that i'm
going to stop doing zelda theories i
love zelda theories and i love geeking
out over zelda it's just that not only
do i love zelda theories i also like
doing mario theories right or or
non-nintendo game theories and then on
the flip side not only do i like uh
doing theories but i also like doing you
know top tens or reviews or vlogs you
know or or whatever um
and the reason why i'm hesitant to just
go forward and do this sort of thing
is is because i i don't want to betray
you guys
because see the way that i see it and
this might not be the way that it is i
don't know but the way that i see it is
there are so
many of you guys on the channel over 160
000 people
who have subscribed to this channel
for zelda theories
right
i mean it's true i know that that's true
because that's
95 of what's on my channel and so i
don't want to betray
that expectation you know what i mean
so
i'm just i guess i'm just asking you
guys if it's okay if i start branching
out
into other things you know maybe if i
want to talk about
you know if i want to review another
game if i can upload it to this channel
if i want to review a movie you know
uh people like video game donkey man
video game dunky video game is in his
name that dude talks about movies
whenever the heck he wants to or penguin
zero here on youtube most critical on
twitch that guy talks about whatever he
wants to
now obviously they're much much bigger
than i am but that's not what i'm
talking about i'm talking about the
kinds of content that they
can do and that their community respects
them for i don't want to betray you guys
so
i want to ask you straight up if you
would be interested in seeing me do
stuff like that on this channel because
if not then i won't and i mean that
honestly if not then i will not
stray that far from the zelda theory
formula that has been working on this
channel
um actually this this this very concept
is why i started bandit plays
because like i was uh mentioning earlier
in this whatever kind of video this is
like i was mentioning earlier i had
let's plays on this channel at one point
in time i just wanted this to be my
everything channel you know where i
uploaded whatever i wanted to do but
like i said i don't want to
betray you guys expectations and make it
to where you're expecting one thing and
then when you see another it's just
you lose interest in in everything
you know like that's a risk that i see
and that's a real risk that i run with
every video
and to some extent you just kind of have
to get over it but
we're talking about the entirety of what
mass intended bandit is based on
and that's why i'm asking you guys if
it's okay
um on that note by the way for those of
you who are curious about what exactly
is up with bandit plays well bandit
plays is is
gonna it's
really honestly the only connection that
bandit plays has to this channel mass
nintendo bandit is me
um other than that bandit plays is going
to operate and feel completely
differently um at first i wanted to talk
about the games here that i play over
there and i might end up doing that
depending on what you guys feel about
what i'm talking about here uh but
ultimately bandit plays is going to be a
channel that's a lot like the
honestly that's
a lot like markiplier or jacksepticeye
or or pewdiepie and obviously those are
titans of youtube and i'm not trying to
say that i'm going to be like them in
size but i'm going to be like them in
terms of what i do on that channel
aka whatever i want so you know i might
that's going to be the channel where i
am just
me you know what i mean like i i'm not
necessarily going to maybe review stuff
on that channel like i'll save that for
mass nintendo bandit but uh i'm going to
play whatever the heck i want to over
there and if i want to upload a skit i'm
going to upload it over there probably
um anyway that that's neither here nor
there you don't if if that's not what
you're into you don't have to worry
about that at all mass nintendo bandit
is still going to be
mass nintendo bandit um this is just a
conversation about
what
could potentially happen with the
content right here on mass nintendo
banner anyway i feel like i've been
rambling for forever and i look at the
timer here and i'm actually surprised
it's only
sitting at uh 12 minutes because um i
feel like i've been talking for like an
hour but
that's probably just because i'm sitting
here in a room talking to a camera
anyway um
just to wrap everything up
first and foremost and most importantly
thank you guys so much for being here i
i
i love you guys you guys are
amazing you've given you've literally
given me a new life and especially those
of you who who hopped on the bandit crew
you know who bought some merch or are
supporting on patreon and stuff like
that
please never feel obligated to do stuff
like that that
you guys melt
my heart
seriously i i hope you understand that
uh anyway but uh so yeah first and
foremost thank you guys for being here
love you guys secondly
i'm asking you earnestly if it's okay if
i start to do other things on this
channel in addition to zelda theories
okay so not exclusive one way or another
i'll do zelda theories but i'll also do
reviews or top tens or vlogs or you know
whatever is that okay would you guys be
interested in seeing me do that sort of
thing anyway that's about it i think i i
keep looking at the screen and for oh my
dad's calling again
okay well
i probably do have to get this but
anyway this is masentino bandit looking
forward to seeing you guys in the next
one thank you so much for watching love
you guys let me know what you think uh
signing out peace where's the off but